こんにちははじめ社長です考古
差を9 notes ノギョン回にあたる
私が最近に作った寝室でございます
teeそれでねますちょっとパッと見て
いきましょう寝る口が肥えてあって野菜
入りますとはい
でこういう感じですねけっこう広いし余裕
を持た寝室になってますベッド猫からは
なんと
[音楽]
pou
dou
douどうぞありがとうございます
さあありようを考えてみてください
終了は分からないでしょざーっと見てそん
ときに何か変哲もないように見えるんです
けどおぉおおぉ
[音楽]
これ
偽物の壁ですこれは偽物なカフェなんです
もう完璧に色は一緒につけてもらったんだ
けどこれ偽物です来られるんですよ大臣が
どうなるかこれ普通のために必要な日目は
はいこっちは
はずだ彼らは生まれます割れば普段ですね
これカメなくて奥にもう1部屋あるんです
よというわけで中ですここに壁版で入るん
ですけどなんかこういう感じになってます
はい
普通に俺のねお着替えでみたいな感じだっ
たんですけども始めてくる人はこれ気付か
ないかなって僕は思いますそれをそれをで
ね特注
花弁してもらいましたせこいちょっと公園
けど結構急いからにしてもらって別に
付き合うれるになっててちょっと今から
壁突き破ってみようと思いますあの者と
安全のために多くに所スタッフはいますし
たのかなぁ床にですか
あれならブーブーってハリーポッターが9
と3/4番線じゃないけどなんかないか
なー文字して壁に突っ込むことないかな
こう
なぜ一間いきまーす
ooooooooooooooooooooo
ooooパック
多分しか見えないいい
いいいいっ
ええええええさぁ声も家でコードどっちに
しろ上に仕掛け人がちゃんとやらないと
短剣をとってあります
できますね
ああああああああ
どうなってましたあんまり記憶ないんです
けれどもこういう感じで壁を突き抜けます
金麦で今回この家の構造を知っている人
だったらこの部屋の多くにもう1にあるの
はわかってるんですけどもこの部屋に
あんまり詳しくない人だったら絶対ちゃっ
たのか女だと思うんですよターゲット本屋
に選んで俺がなんとかバーンてやって壁に
ぶつかると思ったら付抜けるとき
になっていきたいとおもいます小出初夏
くっつき抜けるって結構やばいと思うんで
かなりリアクションが楽しみだしてこの
企画外お金がかかっております結構あの
偽物の壁作るの高いんですよしっかりと
楽しんでいきたいとおもいますで梅香
軽い
4分
を a
こーこちゃこちゃ
行為
仏壇用ため
[音楽]
オメガきた方がられん何回かありますおお
そうですかじゃあねめちゃくちゃ綺麗です
ね
さと家っぽい
この箱の24グラム
aigo 0
ブーブーたら
兄を喰え上げますああああ
[音楽]
ぬーっ
13名53かあさんハイ改めていきます
会津
何キロですか
53キロお願いしますぴったりです
あそうかうわぁ
53点に入っ
よくわかんなちゃすぐ飲んで下さいお願い
しますいます
おおーー
平山今日ですが
52.6です
ああああ
ああ
[音楽]
a という2億円獲得ならずということで
ああ今の感想は
バー
ハ
お揃いにしやがれ
ん
5 a 8の壁た人はどうか今よ
なんかなと雰囲気れてますな今回すごい
びっくりしました
体重
ピッタリ合ってたら surf
[音楽]
ブーブーてるんで earth . com
ロック14.2を居住部分に宮崎きました
が64.2ですよっては上で60でに披露
そうですね64でねー
[音楽]
ブーバー
しえっ
ぽちん
は今日しかないね頭じゃねーのっ
ん
ませ
[音楽]
ブーブーにょme
いいでしょうめっち
って言うと思う
しろっていうねあー見えるという中でああ
で止まりました
体重ビットエンダー
20万円やー
[拍手]
ブーブー
言っ
はおおーー
さっそく乗ってみてください
いやーはいマジかよいきますよ4無事て
ないよはいお願いします
どうぞ
ぐうっさあ r
6帖3でよまっさ
がっ
すごいですいい
meはあああ
ああ
ああああああああ
あっ
[音楽]
は blr